[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
choose your gender define your genetic
structure
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
take your fur type
[Music]
choose your first style pick your main
color choose your detail color good
choice
[Music]
Adventure is in the air despite the
static energy shrouding the radioactive
rulings below oh no they got you reeled
in and off to a bad start
tribes are out force Kroenke scrap your
whiff flip is up next
right off the top
the tribes caught a fluffy hope that a
watcher is a pet
I
shoe is ready
which
Oh
[Music]
that emergency kiss from the old days
when you needed to pack a punch I
survived Wow bet that nook makes a tight
fist
tunnels like this still carry echoes
from the past
the jug yard where they parked the
choo-choos and fuel them up it's one of
the few places that's aged well it used
to look like a dump it's easy to walk
the line when your karma is imbalance
spilled liquid soap is always a slippery
slope you'd expect that a Bubble Bobble
big enough to go back
a tribe flip-flopper will throw you in
at the beat and given the chance
make that one day
this box one stale the chugga-chugga now
it's just all tribes always scavenging
for scrap
both were members missing craps banging
the door mrs. chance
with
rope something
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
the divisions that sprocket before it
blows up in your face
yes you can do anything only the sky is
the limit now let's take this back to
you
Wow you really took that all the way
down to the end in flames
[Music]
it's a wonder some of these up and down
still work yes they do plushie is better
in the house I need to brush up on my
one go but I seen he says he surprised
the girl anyways he says you only won
and he has something in mind he's almost
done with his latest creation a metal
boy
please don't blow on glory why not talk
please don't ask him too many go along I
think he likes you opanka P he can't
leave his own in the young
they're short of breath and death to
this zone better take care hee-hoo half
breathes have lives for those that work
metal scrap from mechs Kronk's like this
are heavy wait
there are only a few reasons our world
is dying and all of them could have been
avoided waiting for prey
the grease monkey's neck bone is
filtered just like Intel
can you imagine how this place used to
look before the dead all flow
in the old roads like this really nice
now most of the disaster
pew-pew
the Jumbo puppies keeping in operation
petracles
target
what about feeling about this goes all
the way down to the staff
stop like a snack and he'll end with a
ride down the intestinal canal that's
too close to the end state the way we
swept out better pumped out them flush
down
see it's what many is the powers that be
towards it already offbeat's the Taurus
is pumping at half a beat
it would go down with a throw up can you
really get any better
and as one plague ends hope through new
beginning leaves on the tree of life
still stands with the fate of the world
you are
question is will you continue to defend
it
as we just have to to find out
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Oh